bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale de nous sommes à
ottawa au musée de l'histoire en fait
jeudi ottawa et j'ai dit la même chose
tout à l'heure nous sommes à gatineau
à quelques pas d'ottawa je m'appelle
anne-marie vos émissions spéciales je
vous en parlais la semaine dernière sur
le rapport de l'aij fada alors elle fera
date c'est un terme qu'on utilise
maintenant depuis deux ans et demi
enquête nationale sur les femmes et les
filles autochtones assassinées et
disparues
le rapport final a été dévoilée
aujourd'hui
pour nous en parler il y avait quatre
commissaires qui ont travaillé donc sur
qui sur ce rapport mais qui ont
rencontré les gens les femmes dans les
communautés qui leur ont demandé de
témoigner donc ces témoignages la ont
duré presque deux ans et demi sur ceux
sur cette enquête
madame michèle audette commissaire
francophone bonjour michel bonjour est
ce que ça va bien est ce que ça va mieux
et est ce que vous êtes soulagé
maintenant que le rapport est sur la
table il est connu de tous ça va mieux
et ça va bien depuis
en avril c'est vrai alors aujourd'hui
avec tout l'amour l'énergie les messages
qu'on va avoir reçu ma famille mes
enfants et les gens qui ont milité
critiquer ou soutenu les travaux de
l'enquète louis depuis plusieurs lunes
vont être présents là alors j'ai comme
fait lâcher prise il ya au mois de
janvier je dirais d'accepter que ou
est-ce que j'étais bien fort avec les
femmes qui nous partagent la vérité de
tomber dans un aspect plus intellectuel
hackett des médecins en effet législatif
dans l'écriture de sévérité là qu'ils
deviennent des moules mais une fois que
j'ai lu le rapport
cet hiver au complet je suis devenu tout
zen
alors nous avons demandé à notre
auditoire de vous poser des questions
nous aurons nos propres questions mais
avant de se lancer dans les questions ma
collègue laurent spinosi bonjour laurent
ce jour et avec vous lors ans on va
résumer évidemment c'est un énorme
rapport y fait plus de 200 pages donc un
résumé à survol des des points forts de
ce rapport d'abord sur ce qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir on est tous d'accord
c'est le terme génocide d'enquêté lui
disait 122 x dans le rapport donc il
fait 1200 pages environ
on parle d'un génocide tout court donc
pas de génocide culturel comme c'était
le cas avec la commission
vérité-réconciliation 2015
donc la grande enquête sur les
pensionnats autochtones on avait parlé
de culturel là on parle de génocide tout
court et donc gg dg des citations
peut-être dû du rapport il y en a
tellement et je les connais pas tout
peut-être mais il ya des citations très
forte j'en ai une
ce pays en guerre et les femmes
autochtones en état de siège
une autre peut-être même si le génocide
canadien vise tous les peuples
autochtones
il s'est particulièrement les femmes les
faits et les personnes alors la personne
de
lgbt qu ia autochtone alors là on a un
terme très inclusif que pas grand monde
connaissait je crois c'est pour big bih
spirituel lesbienne gay bisexuelle
transgenre quirant questionnement
intersexe asexuels personne n'a été
oublié parce que personne nous aurions
manqué des gens qui vont sûrement mais
on a essayé
oui je pense que ça a réuni outre
jean-louis après ça on parle aussi un
génocide planifié fondée sur la race
l'identité et le genre alors le canada
reconnue déjà dans son passé d des
génocides dans le passé contemporain
dans tant d'autres pays on allait le
cost on à l'arménie on a le rwanda cette
fois ci qu'est ce qui va arriver on sait
pas trop monsieur trudeau s'est prononcé
à midi il a dit plusieurs choses il a
donc lieu dit que le rapport ne serait
pas de table était donc peut-être ça
fait du bien d'entendre ça c'est une
promesse par contre il n'a pas dit le
mot génocide et on entendait dans la
salle il y avait des gens qui voulaient
qui criait génocide ne signale pas de
vie alors michel
vous attendiez-vous à ce qu'il prononce
le mot génocide
écoutez ses implications juridiques ans
et c'est toute une question
qui qui mérite cette réflexion là avec
tous les experts en droit international
au canada ici évidemment puis en droit
autochtone oui puis je m'attendais à ce
qu'ils parlent qui a eu une
reconnaissance avec le rapport de vérité
réconciliation du mot génocide culturel
oui mais en même temps elle avait des
élections
il n'y a pas eu le temps de faire
peut-être un exercice de politiciens et
de premier ministre
c'est sûr j'étais déçu parce que quand
le vice est amer on le voit puis on
découpe même moi quand j'étais plus
jeune le génocide c'était le low cost ou
le rwanda et avec l'exercice de
l'enquète nationale j'ai dit mais mon
dieu on tombe partout dans l'article 2
abcd au niveau des moments forts et
président de l'histoire ici au canada en
caisse et les autochtones qui ont été
affectés par ces violences coloniales et
vous pensez que la définition du terme
génocide va aussi loin que ça quand on
parle de ce qui est arrivé au canada
dans notre analyse que vous allez voir
où ils public et de façon normale
cette fois-ci public annoncé aujourd'hui
la cette analyse là on explique le
génocide lorsque c'est très flamboyant
la définition avait été fait à l'époque
jamais les peuples autochtones avait été
partie prenante dans cette réflexion le
débat et les exemples oui alors c'était
encore les gens qui appelait le système
colonialiste qui ont décidé que 1 du
génocide c'est ça le gros risque pour
leurs défilés et voilée oui voilà
alors laurent juge leys pour suivre des
recommandations peut-être qu'on pourrait
en sortir quelques une note de 131 dont
les comptes et la semaine dernière qui
touche toutes sortes de sujets la
culture la gouvernance la sécurité on va
on va vraiment partout peut-être ddd des
recommandations qui nous ont semblé
important on y vient de plusieurs
importantes mais la création de poste
d'un bâtiment pour le droit des
autochtones
ce sens et une ensuite une autre la
création d'un tribunal des droits des
autochtones et des droits humains et des
droits d
oui c'est ça ensuite de se reparlent
d'organiste civile de surveillance de la
police alors quand les enquêtes touchant
les autochtones
on aimerait avoir des organismes pour
les surveiller donc des organismes bien
financier des financiers robustes
comptait aussi
quoi d'autre un plan d'action national
ça aussi c'est énorme et ça toucherait
tous les paliers de gouvernement là on
parle du fédéral les provinces des
territoires
voilà et avec la participation des
femmes des filles les familles touchées
paris et le rapport est sorti vendredi
ont ils auraient dû sortir aujourd'hui
il est sorti vendredi un rapport et là
on a appris par contre aujourd'hui qui
avait aussi un volet québécois
oui vingt-et-une recommandations
associés à ce volet québécois
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur le volet
paix alors le volet québécois
on n'en est pas là un tout petit peu
tout à l'heure c'est la seule le québec
est la seule province qui a droit à un
traitement spécial c'est à dire où il
volait un complément qui est dédié
seulement à une province d'être dans le
québec
donc peut-être en termes de
recommandation il est le protecteur du
citoyen ainsi commentateurs de citoyens
destinés aux peuples autochtones aux
autochtones donc on a ça aussi un appel
au gouvernement provincial donc au
gouvernement le goût de par une enquête
sur les enfants disparus les enfants
autochtones
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait vu
beaucoup pendant les cinq ans les
audiences on passe au québec on avait vu
une norme et manque que deux d'enfants
qui vivent dans un hôpital pour être
soigné et on en entend plus parler
klein au québec et vous l'aviez vous
l'aviez dit à la fin de
l'exemple de la des audiences à montréal
quand malioténam et donc donc voilà donc
je pense que c'est ce qu'on retient paul
g
là je la laisse retourner lire s'il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire
merci de le rendre si mes amis alors on
va y aller tout de suite avec une
question ainsi vous voulez parce qu'il
en a eu plusieurs sur le site une
question de pierre il dit en 2019 qui
tue le plus les femmes autochtones les
autochtones ou les non autochtones
le ma réponse doit être sincère on doit
sortir de ce débat là pour s'assurer que
toutes les femmes notamment les femmes
autochtones soient en sécurité protéger
et ce en toute dignité
voilà question longue mais réponse très
simple et très courte une autre question
et je vais la pause et tout de suite
c'est celle de marie-eve bord de l'eau
marie-eve et la commissaire aux affaires
à la vie elle dit comment allez vous
aider les institutions et les
municipalités à la mise en oeuvre des
appels à la justice et des
recommandations
si nous avions été en mesure d'avoir la
prolongation que nous avions espéré très
très espéré cet exercice que j'appelle
démocratique de mettre sur pied une
commission d enquête comme celle ci
avait aussi un objectif d'éduquer
insiste important alors sachant qu'il ya
un refus dans le ciment doit terminer
les travaux
il nous reste quelques semaines alors là
on espère et on souhaite que le
gouvernement du canada et du québec avec
ce qui existe comme recommandation ah
oui les appelle les appels à la justice
win qu'ils puissent voir leurs
responsabilités leur imputabilité pilar
et du cians ton et à travers cette
responsabilité là c'est aussi de
s'assurer que tout le monde pour
répondre à madame bordeaux doivent être
en mesure de bien comprendre alors c'est
de donner les outils nécessaires
comment ça va se passer justement
maintenant qu'on aime en l'enquète
concrètement elle
aujourd'hui c'était un moment important
un moment très fort dans ce qu'on nous a
ordonné de faire donc le dépôt du
rapport met tantôt mais demain samedi
dimanche et le reste des jours jusqu'au
30 juin à minuit
nous sommes encore en pourparlers avec
le gouvernement fédéral avec les
provinces et territoires au sujet de
deux dossiers de l'histoire qu'on va
avoir entendu de vérité pour s'assurer
qu'on utilise ne pouvoir jusqu'à la fin
alors le rapport dont cap ça a pris deux
ans et demi avant l'évènement ça arrive
sur la table les recommandations il y en
a donc beaucoup de 130 et une à long
terme
comment vous voyez le travail qui va
être effectué par ce qu'ont déjà on
entre en élection très bien mais trop ça
peut changer beaucoup de choses
ça peut ça peut s'il ya eu une enquête
nationale
ouais c'est grâce à un mouvement
oui faut honorer sa faut respecter ça
que la mobilisation des familles va
avoir obligé un gouvernement à se
positionner et mettre en place cette
enquête la laquette se termine le
mouvement maintenant lui existe oui et
on lui donne les outils nécessaires
juridique académique scientifique humain
et émotionnelle et spirituelle pour
continuer ce débat-là continuer ce
mouvement là pour s'assurer justement
dans le cadre d'une campagne électorale
d'un gouvernement qui vient d'être élu
tu a ordonné cinq personnes maintenant
quatre affaires ce mandat-là sera par là
tu es responsable maintenant répond
donne moi tes réponses donc cette
importance sauf faut le faire et c'est
sûr que certains certaines vont
redevenir libre après la commission
bancaire et moi ce jeu mais en fait un
devoir de continuer à éduquer par
rapport aux travaux de lanquais parce
que maintenant le travail des
commissaires
il est
presque terminé complètement trente
jeunes ont rendu le 30 juin doit oui on
a encore des dossiers en cours avec le
gouvernement fédéral
des choses qui sont pas faciles pour sa
chérie qu on puisse faire tout ce qui
est en notre pouvoir quand vous regardez
le décret on a aussi cette
responsabilité si on reçoit une vérité
est qu'on trouve qu' il ya motif
raisonnable
un endroit que l'on devrait te dire à
l'institution il ya peut-être quelque
chose d'anormal ici on se trouve loeb
cette preuve les avec la vérité de la
personne oui alors ça aussi on travaille
très fort
sept jours sur sept pour faire les
messages nécessaires à toutes les
institutions auxquelles on pense que il
ya des choses qui doit être vue l'ouïe
alors cette fois ci une question de
germaine germaine dit c'est injuste les
coupables ne sont pas arrêtées et court
toujours
que font les autorités et que fait la
gendarmerie royale du canada et des jeux
10 ans germaine qu'en effet d'un dans le
rapport on le dit ça aussi oui on nous
demande de trouver les causes des mii
qu'on les trouve et on le voit
aujourd'hui que l'assassinât la
disparition le meurtre la violence
adresses auxquelles vont faire face les
femmes autochtones ou et fait en sorte
que les personnes qui vont commettre ce
crime ne sont même pas punis alors c'est
pour ça qu'on dit un endroit les appels
à la justice vont de l'ordre du concept
de recommandation elles ont une
responsabilité juridique donc la justice
doit s'en mêler
absolument toutes les justices dans tous
les gouvernements et évidemment la
justice au canada et de là l'importance
des tribunal de reddition de comptes et
d'impact d'imputabilité et si on se met
pas ces mécanismes en place comme
société oui ça va donner quoi d'avoir
investi autant d'énergie de rage et de
péret et de vérité et d'argent aussi
pour ce grand projet là qu'il enquête
nationale haut et on parlait de ce volet
québécois qui est un peu à part on
parlait de la réalité des femmes au
québec par rapport aux autres en fait
c'est qui est il ya un isolement pour
les femmes québécoises
entre autres juste du fait qu'elles ne
parlent pas la même langue
comment est-ce qu'on peut rouler feinte
qui habite au québec mais leur seconde
langue c'est l'anglais aussi puis les
navires sur wii alors en fait il y à ces
femmes isolées qui elle ne parle
peut-être pas l'anglais mais ya celles
qui parlent anglais qui ne parlent pas
le français au québec donc comment faire
pour résoudre cet isolement comment
faire pour que les voix de ces femmes là
soit entendu c'est ce qu'on a remarqué
il ya cette belle mobilisation l'oeil à
ce mouvement là que ce soit pour la
culture là l'identité culturelle où tout
ce qui touche cette tragédie qui est la
perte d'un être cher
on va remarquer que la solidarité risque
d'être moins forte en hausse heures au
québec qui parle français comme seconde
langue et celle du reste du canada donc
on empêche de nourrir un débat où une
réflexion et de le rendre un peu plus
fort avec une expertise des femmes au
québec
alors ça ça on démonte mais la solution
n'est pas facile on peut pas forcer
quelqu'un parle anglais et l'autre à
parler français mais il ya des choses
qui qui doit se faire et qui se fait
aussi et d'avoir cette ouverture
d'esprit
pas parce que je parle pas anglais que
mon point de vue n'est pas pertinent
aujourd'hui les femmes se rencontraient
et savez vous comme un spa où elles se
parlent est celle qu'ils ne parlent pas
l'autre langue avec jeu pourquoi sur
leur cellulaire traducteur oui sur les
cellules après s'amuser ou échanger sur
leur culture d'origine d'où elle venait
chez période des fêtes on parlait du 6
mois de prolongation tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que ça aurait donné de plus de
six mois est ce que par exemple terme
génocide non plus culturelle mais
génocide tout simplement serait arrivé
aussi six mois plus tard est-ce qu'il
aurait été encore possible de parler
d'un génocide
oui oui hier était possible de parler
d'un génocide saut c'est sûr parce que
nous avons tellement accumulé et reçu de
preuves chaque appel à la justice
est basée sur des preuves qui émane des
femmes des experts et des gardiens faut
savoir avoir eu le temps comme on l'a
demandé on aurait pu aller dans
plusieurs endroits au québec fallait
quatre commissaires au québec pour être
réduites pour être conforme avec le
décret ça l'amène sont aussi un
empêchement de faire venir les autres
commissaires j'aurais été partout oui
alors plus de temps on les aurait fait
venir dans d'autres endroits au québec
où de se rapprocher des femmes qui ont
peu été en mesure de venir partager leur
vérité un autre point important avec la
prolongation
l'objectif était d'aller dans chaque
province et territoire parce qu'on a
tout d d d d enquête avec chaque
gouvernement dans le populeux fin donc
je me suis assuré qu'avec le
gouvernement du québec on dépose comme
commissaire un rapport oui alors
maintenant il a fallu faire avec et
voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui mais
quand même un travail incroyable qui a
été au cours des dernières années c
c'est incroyable de il ya quelques temps
ou moi même ébranlé par cette machine là
cette entité qui l'emmène de gérer tout
ça de mettre sur pied quelque chose qui
ait jamais existé en 6 pts 1 et 2 dans
ma passion de trouver qu'on pourrait
aller plus loin et faire en sorte que
c'est juste qu'on est donc de se
réorganiser et en faisant la lecture du
rapport c'est là que j'ai vu mais il ya
tellement de choses fortes puissantes
qui viennent de nous les femmes
autochtones oui c'est les chercheurs
c'était des femmes autochtones les
avocates ce n'est pas maintenant la
plupart des comme ça se défend m
c'est incroyable alors moi c'est une
grande fierté dont et accompagne aussi
de courageux et courageuses canadiens
canadiennes étaient super le fun qu'une
belle équipe du québec oui les femmes
autochtones je le voyais aujourd'hui il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui étaient là
pour évidemment les aider à passer à
travers ces étapes difficiles elles ont
été là tout au long du processus
elle était encore là aujourd'hui toutes
ces personnes-là des prochains mois est
ce qu'elles auront encore de
l'accompagnement d'important c'est une
bonne question
elles ont elles devraient l'avoir
enquête au poker on emballe longtemps
dans leur rapport qu'il faut pas une
commission d'enquêté pour soutenir une
personne qui est un droit fondamental
oui ok ou alors on démontre aussi une
violation d'un droit ce qu'on a remarqué
lorsque l' enquête a été annoncé le
gouvernement fédéral a annoncé aussi des
organisations dans chaque province et
territoire qu'on appelle luc les unités
de liaison le pour les familles alors
chaque province et territoire le québec
a été très actif avec monsieur caron
très très très proches des familles
c'est ce que j'ai eu comme eco et je
tiens à leur merci ça c'est important
aujourd'hui on a une famille nous qui
viennent est embauchée j'ai su ça qui va
s'impliquer dans l'ue cliff et dans
chaque province et d'autres personnes
pour rassurer jusqu'en 2020 c'est qu'ils
vont avoir témoigné ou des familles qui
ont pas témoigner mais qui ont perdu un
être cher puisse avoir le soutien
nécessaire mais 2020 quand on parle de
500 ans d'une violence coloniale
multigénérationnel inter-générationnelle
puis d'une marginalisation sociale et
économique c'est pas en douze mois que
joueur régler quelque chose qui me fait
très mal
absolument est-ce que vous pensez que ça
va prendre plusieurs générations pour
sortir de ce marasme là oui ça va
prendre plusieurs générations faut être
patient la génération elle est déjà en
marche
elle est déjà en mode de guérison mais
faut pas oublier qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas eu le privilège de
ceux et celles qui sont en marche vers
la guérison et l'état à une obligation
juridique à la une
elle a une obligation si social de
s'assurer que peu importe où j'habite du
jeu soient protégés que je sois entouré
pour que mon droit à la culture droit la
justice à la sécurité et à la santé soit
respectée peu importe où j'habite
oui
je reviens encore au tng dont va
terminer avec anglet parce que quand le
rapport a été révélée vendredi vont tout
de suite les médias s'en sont emparés et
les titres évidemment c'était une fana
considère que ce qui arrive aux femmes
autochtones office autochtone c'est un
génocide
alors évidemment il ya des gens ça 10 a
choqué des gens ça déjà interpellé
vous n'avez pas crainte que ça crée une
scission division la division elle est
déjà là on va arrêter de prétendre
qu'elle n'existait pas cette division là
pourquoi que tant de femmes qui
disparaissent ou qui sont assassinés ou
qui vivent une violence inacceptable
depuis trop longtemps depuis la création
de ce pays ç'a toujours été là et c'est
encore là et que on va utiliser le plus
grand tribunal canadien qui est la cour
suprême du canada pour aller dire encore
une fois que ma fille a été tuée
sauvagement par cette personne là et
jamais vous avez nommé son nom et on est
en 2019
jamais vous avez nommé son nom vous
l'avais appelé prostituées et indienne
alors qu'elle est une femme une mère
elle avait des rêves et les ma fille
alors que la personne qui a commis le
crime et qui avait reconnu en haut elle
souhait va avoir plein de gens qui vont
venir témoigner en sa faveur il va voir
un nom cet homme l'a fait que ça existe
mais le génocide
il a toujours été là on était gêné de le
dire ou de le prétendre
et le génocide a été créée comme on
disait la définition par des non
autochtones
donc avec ce débat encore sous le dos
des femmes
malheureusement on va nourrir et élever
ce débat là et c'est pas nous vous et
moi et monsieur trudeau 10 c'est
officiellement génocide mais une entité
qui un tribunal qui va faire cette
analyse là et dans ce tribunal et cette
décision là on doit être partis ont le
nom
alors un dernier mot croyez-vous avoir
secoué les consciences et la conscience
des canadiens je pense qu'on a secoué
juste physiquement regardez ce qui s'est
passé hier une tornade une tournade ici
à gatineau nous étions des centaines de
familles si oui alors peut-être que les
gens vont dire de quoi capable moi je
pense que notre énergie et les rendus là
on vibre parce qu'on a le devoir de
ramener ce qu'on a reçu et ces femmes là
et aujourd'hui vont permettre à faire en
sorte que quand le canada vont nations
unies et dit qu'il est fier de ses lois
et 10 de sa façon de faire au niveau des
droits humains et des droits de la
personne
ces femmes vont lui rappeler en train de
le canada devrait partout même dans le
nord merci beaucoup michèle audette
alors merci à vous d'avoir été là
vendredi nous allons poursuivre la
discussion avec des réactions au rapport
dont nous avons invité des autochtones
des non autochtones autour de la table
et nous allons continuer a commenté son
rapport de l' enquête nationale sur les
femmes et les filles autochtones
assassinées et disparues dont ce
vendredi midi 15 c'est un rendez-vous à
très bientôt
merci